une dernière petite question très rapide
sur un autre sujet explosif puisque les
consultations hier vous avez eu ont
aussi apparemment porté sur les grèves
dans les raffineries et la colère la
colère qui monte la droite estime que le
gouvernement a très mal géré cette crise
vous que dites-vous moi ce que je pense
c'est qu'on ne clôture jamais un conflit
social par des réquisitions et c'est ce
rappel la première ministre il y a la
nécessité de réquisitionner le
gouvernement doit faire preuve
d'autorité mais il doit le faire à juste
proportion ensuite les salariés
grévistes et les entreprises doivent
également amener leur part elles doivent
négocier et elles doivent sortir de ce
conflit et ensuite le gouvernement pour
protéger les Français parce
qu'aujourd'hui qui est pris en otage
dans cette histoire si ce n'est les
millions de Français qui n'arrivent pas
à aller travailler qui n'arrivent pas à
amener leurs enfants à l'école donc je
pense que la prise en otage doit cesser
le gouvernement doit agir en fermeté
mais en respectant le dialogue social et
les entreprises concernées leurs
salariés doivent un moment sortir de
crise par la la négociation on va
maintenant
[Musique]